season debut of Reggie Aloysius Miller
jr. the third I love y'all I hate our
layoffs because so much happens in
between and I find myself like twitchy
my fingers are twitching
to grab the phone to call you guys and
just kind of vent but I'm so glad we
were back on our normal cycle and the
nba's is back tonight arguably the best
doubleheader I've been associated with
since I've been working at Turner
because this has drama Flair superstars
intrigue look I'm I'm just fortunate to
have the best seat in the house tonight
for everything that's going on fold I
know it's only one game and it's Game
one so many great storylines tonight
make love and give reg the pole question
okay if you could have your choice of
Finals matchups would you take Cavs
warriors or any other combination Cavs
Warriors and that's what it'll be
Cavs warriors who's the third best team
I know people maybe I know people maybe
tired of seeing that four times in a row
but look you've got the best stars in
the business with Golden State's they're
young they're energetic
they know how to win they're well
coached and they play the right way they
play a very pleasing style of basketball
they shoot threes they great defenders
and then you've got the Cavs which think
about a finals team that had so much
overhaul you got eight new players
veteran players Jeff Green Dwyane Wade I
like what they've done Kobe Altman the
new general manager is that a great job
of peace failing this together to
surround LeBron James with pieces that
can compete and you've got an upstart
young team tonight in the Boston Celtics
Kyrie he wants to spread his wings he
said that that's why he wanted to be
traded he goes to an iconic franchise
like the Celtics and gets a chance to
lead so we've you know we get a little
bit of everything but bottom line at the
end of the day barring major injury yeah
it's going to be the Cavs versus the
Warriors what do you make a Michael
Jordan saying you're going to
one or two teams that are going to be
great another 28 teams that are going to
be garbage well number one one of his
teams you know I thought he was being
too kind he said one or two no it's one
team look Golden State in my opinion is
head and shoulders above everyone else
and you see how everyone and the league
has reacted to that you see these
superstars now wanting to play with one
another to try to band together to go
against that four headed monster so to
me it's one team that is a super team
that everyone is chasing and everyone
else on a given day may beat them but
remember you've got to beat them four
times in a series and I just don't see
anyone being able to do that again
barring major injury what's the one
injury the player who could be injured
that will take down Golden State so of
the big three the guy they can least
afford or you know the big four if you
want to throw in dream on the guy they
can ill afford to lose well I was
certainly thorough dream on in there
they are a legitimate big four and I
said this even if Katie went down they
would still win the championship
remember they were 1901 when he had that
knee injury and missed a significant
amount of time even if clay went down
and they just had KD they were still
when the the championship to me if both
of those two go down and it's just dream
on and clay then that's a different
story but even if one of those two
superstars between Stef and KD are
injured for significant amount of time
there's there's that good and their
style of play because they are so
unselfish and they're well coached and
that'll be more time for Steve Kerr to
be on the sidelines I don't think he'll
be missing as many games as he's done
the last two years I just think they're
that good guys they really are and for
these other teams that with Chris Paul
and James Harden in Houston Melo pg13 in
OKC it's great but they've got to form
that chemistry
and until that chemistry happens Golden
State already has that and they have
chips they understand how to win in
tight situations well these other teams
they're gonna have to fighting their way
and until then Golden State's just going
to be cruising along TNT has a
doubleheader tonight to kick off the
season Cavs and the Celtics
it's the rockets and Golden State reg
will be on the call tonight with the
Celtics and the Cavs we just brought
this up if you're a Cavs fan how do you
greet Kyrie Irving well I'm sure true
Kyrie fans will applaud his six years
but for the fact for his shot and he
never would have had a championship so I
hope people support and understand that
the fans are fickle and when you don't
want to play for us anymore they can
turn the fight the light switch off as
well
from what I understand they are going to
do a video tribute to Kyrie before
player introductions which i think is a
class act for him because he did do a
lot of good things for this franchise
four-time all-star and again I'll say it
but for the fact that big shot in Game
seven in San Francisco they don't win
their championship so I hope they
applaud the efforts but again fans are
fans and I think once jump all happens
he'll be a road player and in opposing
jersey and they'll boo and as they
should
that's what fans are supposed to do but
I hope they appreciate the time that he
was here and they give him a standing
ovation but of course they're going to
boo
not to the level of when LeBron came
back when he was a member of the Miami
Heat
but they will boo I was wondering this
reg if Kyrie has any indication that
LeBron is not going to be there after
this season that can still be your team
with pieces in place there and you don't
have to go to Boston do you wonder if
that's factory because then it's his
table absolutely but it was his team
before LeBron got there while he was
still in Miami and they were cellar
dwellers still I think personally and
this is just me
speculating every game good or bad but
mostly bad this year for the Cavs every
media member is going to come in and ask
everyone on their team well using LeBron
is Dean are gone because LeBron has been
non-committal and I think if you're
Kyrie he doesn't he didn't want to be
attached to that every single game why
do I got to be attached to the bran
Jing's if he's staying or going he
wanted to get ahead of the story and
what's wrong with a young player kind of
wanting to spread his wings you want to
see what he can do on his own now I kind
of wouldn't be kicking dust as I'm on my
way out the door talking about I'm
playing in a great sports city now and
you know real fans and this and that
because that's why fans will boo we
understand you're in Boston where I
understand that you're going and playing
for a team that's won 17 championships
but we did a lot for you as well so yeah
it could have been his teams but I
didn't think he wanted to be tied to
LeBron James decision if he's going to
stay or go with the Cleveland Cavaliers
can you hold on can we bring you back
for a few more minutes what's what's
that I want to ask you what's the most
fun you had on your vacation and then I
want to ask you if you think something
happens prior to or during the anthem
tonight
in Cleveland bull continue with Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. the third right
effort is reg what should we be looking
for with the Lakers this season and in
particular Lanza ball well obviously
young players and their growth bonds of
all obviously a rookie but Julius Randle
Brandon Ingram the leap that they
hopefully will make because to me that's
how the Lakers will become a powerhouse
again your young players have to make
those huge significant gains and get
better and I think to me once that
happens it'll be easier to attract the
free agents when you see the internal
growth of these young players
I know everyone's talking about they're
making the playoffs and the West is so
loaded this year and to put that kind of
pressure
on a rookie like Lanza ball I think he's
fantastic I think he's one of those
throwback players on a Jason Kidd where
all he wants to do is get his teammates
involved so we'll see that but I'm sure
they'll take their lumps because they
are a young team but I want to see the
internal growth of those young players
but Reggie is his Lonzo ball even the
best rookie on his own team no that
might be called Kusa yeah I had a chance
to watch a lot of him while he was at
Utah a lot of time oh he's a good player
and at that size he's a perfect
prototypical player for the NBA he can
shoot it from distance can play with his
back to the basket runs the floor like a
thoroughbred so he may not be the best
rookie on his team but he'll have the
biggest impact in my opinion because if
someone has to get Kuzma the ball and
that's going to be Lonzo ball any word
of a show support protest tonight before
the anthem er during the anthem you know
initially I thought yes because we live
in a copycat society but the NBA you
know the more I thought about it we've
always been at the forefront of whether
it be racial injustice or social issues
the NBA has kind of always been a step
ahead so I wouldn't be surprised if
probably more teams would probably have
linked arms and probably no kneeling not
that I would have a problem with that
because I think the message has been
lost on why mr. Kaepernick has been
doing it all along and wants to you know
the the president got involved and
talked about you know firing guys and
kicking them out of the league they made
it more about you know the the veterans
and the military and the flag and it had
nothing to do with that it had to do
with racial injustice and police
brutality and that's the message
I really believe has been lost on why
you know Colin was kneeling in the first
place but I don't think we'll see any of
that tonight but I think most teens will
probably be linked in arms what would
you have done if you played in the NFL
now yes in the NFL yeah number one I
probably would have been in the NFL at
185 no I you know it's it's it's a lot
of frets a lot of pressure you know I
see where Kobe came out and said he
would be kneeling that you know coming
from the military background where you
know you respect the flag but again it
has nothing to do with the flag but
growing up on the base that's all we
knew was you know Liberty and God in our
country and you respect that at all cost
so it I'm still torn but what side of
history do you want to be on and we just
you know people want things right here
in America that's all we want we want a
seat at the table and we want to be
heard and I hope people can respect what
mr. Kaepernick and these people are
doing just to bring light to it and I
hope people understand it has nothing to
do with the flag and the veterans and
the military because we all and I
personally respect that growing up in a
military household but we just want to
sit at the table and make things fair
for everyone give people that don't have
a voice a voice give me the sneaky team
this year I really like the Denver
Nuggets out west are they trying meeting
a miniature version a smaller version of
the Golden State Warriors
they don't have this shooting denver
does but between nikolai Djokovic and
Paul Millsap two very skilled big men
and if their guards can't get on the
right page Murray and Gary Harris who
just signed a big deal there are a
sneaky team out west and to me I know
everyone's talking about Boston and
Cleveland Milwaukee could make
Kim Gaines if everyone can stay healthy
Brogdon obviously auntie to Khun pho but
this is the year Milwaukee could make
that next step and be in the discussion
of being an Eastern Conference finalist
what's the coolest thing you did this
summer well usually I would say by trip
to Hawaii I was there two and a half
weeks but the coolest thing was filming
that uncle drew movie for a month
straight in Atlanta I didn't think I
would ever put the shoes back on and
have a chance to compete but to be a
part of you know a feature film wait
explain what it's about Ridge oh this is
the uncle drew film based off of Tyrese
character who Kyrie is the star of it
uncle drew where we are I didn't like
the two and a half three hours in
prosthetic makeup every morning but once
we got all that on and actually had a
chance it's it's the old band getting
back together so it's Connery Shaq who
plays big fella Chris Webber who plays
preacher Nate Robinson who plays boots
myself who plays lights lights out our
guys I can shoot but really can I like
that and Lisa Leslie Betty Lou who's
married to preacher so those are the
principal actors basketball players
slash actors and we play like 75 80 year
old versions of ourselves and it is a
hilarious comedy and getting let me go
back a second getting a chance to be
around Kyrie for that month let me just
tell you this you know you talked about
will he get booed Kyrie could care less
by the way he doesn't give a yeah he is
a very mature 25 year old guy so he
wasn't fazed by what he's not going to
be faced by what's going to come his way
he just wants to go out and ball so he
doesn't worry about the naysayers people
doubting him he's a little bit of head
of schedule in terms of maturity so
ready who's the best actor on set since
he retired I felt I needed to be a true
thespian in being character for the
whole month so I was even hotter I was
in character for a month straight and
respect for Daniel day-lewis retirement
or exactly oh yeah see we have a picture
of them up IMDB has a picture of them
all in their makeup yeah oh my god did
they look awesome
they look it's hilarious 2018 the film
will drop in movie theaters trust me it
is bleep funny and the basketball she's
a good thing about it see Webb and I
took over all the basketball scenes to
make it because when you watch
basketball movies and you know this
Theodore you'd like that wouldn't happen
doesn't happen we made sure that the
basketball scenes were legit so see
whatever and I took it over that's the
problem I can play you know white men
can't jump you're not doing that on a
playground come on no you're not so we
made sure that all the basketball things
were legit and like we go back to the
Rucker Lee even though this was shot
somewhere else this is all supposed to
be done in New York City and the Rucker
League so we made it we made it look
legit
Shaq is so big reg I tell people oh my
god you can't even when you see him you
know he's big when you're next to him I
don't know if there's a bigger man on
the planet and not only that look at his
makeup that's a seven-foot Wolverine
right there trailer looking like that
looking like Logan there would be more
in today's NBA you were shank I would
sack of the dinosaur not quite why sure
Shaq could play in today's game wait he
couldn't be throwing those elbows around
we would just move Shaq away from the
basket well we tried to do that in the
finals and we all saw how that happened
oh you know what yeah well that Shaq
would be Shaq would be more valuable
really I mean red you would average 25 I
don't know it would Shaq dominate even
though the game is not inside out like
it used to be you could not stop that
big did that dude you cannot stop Shaq
you couldn't stop them and he was a
willing passer - yeah I guess I was
giving you a little more credit that you
know you'd be raining threes 13 threes a
game and I think I would average about
28 to 30 points
twenty-seven-year-old reg not
50-something year-old hey the 27 year
old reg on the Warriors Houston - I
really out there I would average about
35 because all I had to do is run to the
three-point line
you want to play any D in Houston it's
great oh I love that okay how does that
work out how does Chris Paul make James
Harden and the Rockets better he will
because he will get in their face he
will demand excellence and he will
demand that they give that effort at the
defensive end because that's the type of
leader Chris Paul is it's gonna be weird
though for harden when you have the ball
and you do whatever I mean he would just
keep it I think he he had probably had
more ball time than anybody in the NBA
even Russell Westbrook jr. the third but
I I wonder how that does work when it's
it's Chris Paul who has to lead the show
but it's James Harden show
the last two to three minutes of a close
game for Houston that will be the
intrigue and that's the chemistry part
I've been talking about we'll all this
player movement during the offseason
chemistry is going to be huge this year
for these teams and for these superstars
that are starting to play with one
another you know who's going to have the
ball because you know you just mentioned
it James Harden was spectacular last
year down the stretch but he had the
basketball for Chris Paul to be
successful and what he's done throughout
his whole career is being the set up man
he needs to basketball the one thing
that Mike D'Antoni has going for him the
last couple years doc had taken Chris
Paul off the ball with Austin Rivers and
Raymond Felton kind of having that ball
handling responsibilities down the
stretch so Chris Paul can play off the
basketball we've seen that but both of
those two players need the basketball to
be successful that's what I want to see
is how they build that chemistry reg
will be on the call tonight it'll be the
Cavs and the Celtics and then Thursday
night it'll be the Knicks and the
Thunder opening week are you kidding me
are you David Levy the head of TNT
sports way to suck up French hey great
to have you back have fun tonight we'll
be watching it's gonna be a long
beautiful year I can't wait for our
weekly banter Thank You red the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience